So now, let's look at differential operators for images.
Recall, that we'd looked at how to do various types of efficient methods to
do processing on images, by taking a kernel and applying it to an image.
Well, let's start to build on that concept, but now, actually,
let's use it to be able to do things like differential calculations on images.
So what we need, basically, is an operation that,
when applied to an image, returns its derivatives.
It would be a lot of fun if you can actually create these operators that
are like masks or kernels because we've already learned how to
do things like convolution or cross correlation.
And that would allows to now compute image gradients by
running operations like this.
And of course, then we need to do is,
threshold this gradient information to select images.
We will remember this term again, how to to thresholding to get to edges.
And we'll cover more of this in the next lecture,
when we talk specifically about edges